Lucia: 你要是刚才连的真是L3的话
Lucia: If you really connected to L3 just now
Lucia: L3上应该会有一个我命名的文件
Lucia: There should be a file named by me on L3
Jake:没有他关了
Jake: No, he turned it off
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Jake:所以应该是连不上了
Jake: So it shouldn't be connected
Lucia: 嗯我因为我刚发现
Lucia: Hmm, because I just found out
Lucia: 我这上面还是昨天的文件
Lucia: This is still yesterday's file
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 所以我上一个可能连在了L3上
Lucia: So the last one might have been connected to L3
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 就是这个还是昨天的文件
Lucia: This is still yesterday's file
Lucia: 所以我前面上一个文件可能连在了L3上
Lucia: So the previous file might have been connected to L3
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK OK
Lucia: 然后对所以他现在才才到L4
Lucia: So it just now got to L4
Lucia: 那我要把之前这删掉吗
Lucia: Should I delete the previous one?
Jake:对对对你边录边删都可以
Jake: Yes, you can delete while recording
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Alright
Lucia: 突然变成L3
Lucia: Suddenly it turned to L3
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmph
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry
Lucia: 呃应该还没有呢
Lucia: Uh, it should not be here yet
Katrina: 哦好
Katrina: Oh, okay
Lucia: 没事我们还可以先整理整理
Lucia: No worries, we can organize first
Lucia: 我也要整理一下
Lucia: I need to organize too
Lucia: 哎我刚看到你也挂了小旗子
Lucia: Oh, I just saw you also hung a small flag
Katrina: 我也有一个小旗子
Katrina: I also have a small flag
Lucia: 啊哈
Lucia: Aha
Katrina: 我是动物世界的小旗子哈哈哈
Katrina: I'm the small flag of the animal world, hahaha
Lucia: 好看
Lucia: Looks nice
Lucia: 嗯这是谁的呀
Lucia: Hmm, whose is this?
Katrina: 我给你买一点呗
Katrina: Should I buy you some?
Katrina: 这个东西也很
Katrina: This thing is also very
Katrina: 这几个花瓶我也寄回去算了
Katrina: I'll just send these vases back
Katrina: 因为到时候他那个我们也带不走
Katrina: Because we can't take them with us later
Katrina: 你看你看
Katrina: Look, look
Katrina: 这个地方这一片都是别墅
Katrina: This whole area is full of villas
Katrina: 你看隔的多近的
Katrina: Look how close they are
Katrina: 这一排全是别墅
Katrina: This whole row is villas
Katrina: 对啊都是民宿
Katrina: Yeah, it's all B&Bs.
Katrina: 都是基本上都是租给大家
Katrina: Basically, they're all rented out to everyone.
Katrina: 就是旁边是环球影城嘛
Katrina: Right next to it is Universal Studios.
Katrina: 这边就是民宿
Katrina: And here, it's all B&Bs.
Katrina: bye bye
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Katrina: 他们做的小狗
Katrina: They made a little dog.
Katrina: 放在门口
Katrina: Put it at the door.
Katrina: 自己做的
Katrina: Made it themselves.
Katrina: 他们用纸箱厉害吧
Katrina: They used cardboard, impressive right?
Katrina: 我做的那个压花也可好了
Katrina: The pressed flower I made is also really nice.
Katrina: 这我昨天我拍卖买到的
Katrina: I got this at an auction yesterday.
Katrina: 这是一个胶片
Katrina: It's a film.
Katrina: 这是一个朋友带过来的
Katrina: A friend brought it over.
Katrina: 就是要用光
Katrina: You need light.
Katrina: 才能打出这是大海
Katrina: To project it, it's the ocean.
Katrina: 这买了两个种子
Katrina: I bought two seeds.
Katrina: 就是我们互相拍卖嘛
Katrina: We auction them to each other.
Katrina: 这个就当我们的货币
Katrina: We use it as our currency.
Katrina: 不是用真的钱
Katrina: Not real money.
Katrina: 只是带大家做游戏而已
Katrina: Just for playing games with everyone.
Katrina: 你这人真的很没有情趣
Katrina: You really have no sense of fun.
Katrina: 不想跟你说
Katrina: Don't want to talk to you.
Katrina: 这个这个的房间超好看
Katrina: This room is super nice.
Katrina: 你懂啥呀
Katrina: What do you know?
Katrina: 他房间可漂亮了
Katrina: His room is really beautiful.
Katrina: 他们几个女生的手都很巧
Katrina: The girls' hands are so skillful.
Katrina: 心都很细
Katrina: They're very meticulous.
Katrina: 制作特别好看
Katrina: The craftsmanship is excellent.
Katrina: 你知道昨天
Katrina: You know yesterday,
Katrina: 我以为我的房间已经装饰的挺好看的
Katrina: I thought my room was decorated pretty nicely.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 因为第一个参观是我的房间
Katrina: Because mine was the first room to be toured.
Katrina: 然后呢我一推开他们几个的门
Katrina: Then, I opened the door to their rooms.
Katrina: 我说我靠我这个太太简单了
Katrina: I was like, wow, mine is way too simple.
Katrina: 就是明显的那种理工科的那种感觉
Katrina: It has that obvious engineering vibe.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 我我这个装饰
Katrina: My decoration...
Alice:你还挑毛病
Alice: You're still nitpicking.
Alice:你这人是不是欠骂
Alice: Do you need a scolding or what?
其他人：草莓吃
Others: Eat the strawberry
Lucia: 吃
Lucia: Eat
Alice:没洗吧
Alice: Haven't washed it, right?
其他人：对没洗
Others: Yeah, not washed
Alice:你不给洗一下
Alice: Aren't you going to wash it?
Lucia: 没事我来洗
Lucia: It's fine, I'll wash it
Lucia: 我吃一个还有一个
Lucia: I'll eat one, and there's another one
Lucia: 你们俩谁吃
Lucia: Who wants the other one?
Lucia: 那我把两个都吃了
Lucia: Then I'll eat both
Alice:我我我哪懒了
Alice: I'm not lazy at all
其他人：别让我在地上发现瓜子皮
Others: Don't let me find sunflower seed shells on the floor
Lucia: 其他人：
Lucia: Others:
Alice:哎你的掉了
Alice: Hey, you dropped something
Alice:可能手有点大
Alice: Maybe your hands are a bit big
Lucia: 谢谢唉
Lucia: Thanks, ah
Lucia: 怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 可能是我刚才换衣服的时候
Lucia: Maybe it happened when I was changing clothes
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 我应该是换衣服时候把它揣口袋了
Lucia: I probably put it in my pocket while changing
Alice:没干系
Alice: No problem
Alice:我把电给你拔了啊
Alice: I'll unplug the power for you
Lucia: 因为我又要洗裤子了
Lucia: Because I need to wash my pants again
Alice:拔吧
Alice: Go ahead
Lucia: 你有看出来我换了一条裤子吗
Lucia: Did you notice I changed pants?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:没有天呐
Alice: No, oh my god
Alice:给
Alice: Here
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 最后俩你要不要吃一个
Lucia: Do you want one of the last two?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Lucia: 我我慷慨
Lucia: I'm generous
Lucia: 都分给你一个哈哈
Lucia: I'll share one with you, haha
Alice:啊拆不下来了
Alice: Ah, I can't get it open
Alice:你我靠
Alice: You, oh my
Alice:这奶油熏死我了
Alice: This cream is overwhelming
Alice:我不爱闻这个味
Alice: I don't like the smell
Alice:嗯扭一下
Alice: Twist it a little
Lucia: 柯欣和他的小伙伴
Lucia: Kexin and his friends
Lucia: 慷慨的分给了我两个
Lucia: Generously gave me two
Lucia: 你要不要慷慨的
Lucia: Do you want to be generous too?
Jake:那我慷我怎么慷慨
Jake: So how do I show my generosity?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你要不慷慨的还是留给我
Lucia: Hahaha, if you're not generous, just leave it to me.
Jake:哈哈哈我还能如何
Jake: Hahaha, what else can I do?
Lucia: 哈哈哈没事没事你吃一个嘛
Lucia: Hahaha, it's okay, it's okay, you can have one.
Jake:好的慷慨了
Jake: Alright, I'll be generous.
Jake:那我吃一个
Jake: I'll have one then.
Lucia: 你看我相当于分给你1/2的水果
Lucia: Look, it's like I gave you half of my fruit.
Lucia: 我是不是特别慷慨
Lucia: Aren't I super generous?
Jake:嗯对谢谢各位慷慨
Jake: Yeah, thanks everyone for your generosity.
Alice:老板
Alice: Boss.
Alice:我的生命危一危险
Alice: My life is in danger.
Alice:对我的生命安全受到了威胁
Alice: My safety is being threatened.
Jake:好算了
Jake: Okay, never mind.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:他要在地上翻一个瓜子皮就把我腰斩
Alice: If there's a sunflower seed shell on the floor, it'll cut me in half.
Jake:瓜子皮是吧哈哈哈哈
Jake: Sunflower seed shell, huh? Hahahaha.
Alice:已经有了哈哈哈
Alice: There already is one, hahaha.
Lucia: life danger is secure了哈哈
Lucia: Life danger is secure now, haha.
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh.
Jake:你要采集一些不能播的数据
Jake: You need to collect some data that can't be broadcast.
Lucia: 笑的我都噎住了
Lucia: I laughed so hard I choked.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:啊采集些不能拨的数据
Alice: Ah, collect some data that can't be broadcast.
Jake:就是采没有没有
Jake: Just collect, no, no.